but now brands are looking at how
they're spending their dollars and they
have so much a much easier time working
with people with a smaller following who
have a very loyal community that listens
to them and believes them and doesn't
see them as this kind of like sellout
celebrity kind of thing so the
celebrities are not getting their Big
Brand deals anymore because those
dollars are being spent on you know
micro and Nano influencers and Define a
micro and Nano influencer well I don't
think anybody for whatever reason wants
to be called an influencer anymore it
has like this really negative
connotation but basically if you've got
more than a hundred people that are
following you and interacting right and
they're real people then you've got some
influence and that means that brands are
looking at you like okay does this
person have a good relationship with the
people who are communicating with them
is their trust there and they would much
rather do you know hundreds of Nano
influencer deals versus one big Mega
influencer deal where the that person's
hard to work with their rates are
ridiculous uh you can't tell if they've
bought half their followers the
engagement isn't real so they would much
rather work with these people who are
more authentic yeah that's really good
news we talk a lot for small YouTube
creators or smaller channels or across
the platforms micro Nano influencers or
where Brands want to invest their
dollars and the influencer marketing
industry the last numbers we were
looking at was close to 20 billion and
growing about 20 percent a year that's
just that vertical there's so many
different ways to make money just that
one vertical is massive money flowing
into the system so that's actually a
good news dead Trend that the money is
going to Everyday creators